I just took a $10,500 payout in 14
trading days using one free tool on
Trading View. And the big reveal is the
Gone Box. In this video, I'm going to
break down exactly how you too can use
this tool completely for free on Trading
View to get your first futures payout.
Let's get right into it. I'm an advocate
for saving money and staying simple.
Everything that I'm about to show you on
this Trading View chart, you can do for
free. No subscription needed. The first
thing you're going to want to do is go
to gone and Fibonacci tools. Go down to
gone box and highlight the star icon to
add it to your favorites. Next, click on
the gone box. Drag it anywhere on your
chart. Click the cog icon for settings.
Activate zero, one, and five, and then
deactivate all of the time levels. You
can customize whatever color you want. I
like to keep mine neutral.
Now that you have that, you have the 0%,
50%, and 100% retracement levels. I use
these to mark out the London high,
London 50, and London low.
Make sure that you activate the weak
magnet underneath the magnet tools. This
snaps to whatever level forms the high
or low. It makes it easier for you to
identify as opposed to zooming way way
in and then making sure that you're
lined up with the wick. And that's about
it. The other thing that I have
activated is volume. Volume is there for
validation reasons. Uh if the volume's
decreasing as price is going up, it
means it's probably an invalid move to
the upside. Vice versa.
The next thing that you're doing is the
London 50 and previous days 50. Trades
also refers to it as equilibrium. I like
to refer to it as previous days 50 just
because it lines up better with the
London 50. whatever you want to do for
the London 50. The model that you are
trading is you mark out the London low
to London high. That time frame, and I
know London session isn't technically
4:00 a.m. to 9:15 a.m. EST, but it's
close enough for me. So, London low is
any low formed between 4:00 a.m. and
9:15 a.m. EST.
In this case, our London low is right at
the 4 AM candle and our London high was
formed at about 7 o'clock and then it
revisited at 8:30. That forms your
range. So, you use your gone box tool.
And I'll actually delete this one so you
can see exactly what I do. Make sure you
have your weak magnet activated. Go
right to that London low. And you can
see it snaps to it for you. And then
drag it to the London high. And then
drag it out to the right until you have
it lined up within a couple cents. Now
that you have that chart for the day,
those are your levels that you're taking
the reaction off of. You have your
London low, your London 50, and your
London high. At London 50, I take 2 MNQ.
At London high or low, I take 1 MNQ. And
your stop loss is a 15minute closure
above or below the level that you took
that trade on. Always make sure that
you're on the 15-minut time frame as the
fivem minute time frame offers quite a
few fake outs. 15-minut time frame is
going to help significantly with that.
So again, go back to the 15minut.
In this case, I would have taken longs
at about 10:15 10:30 2 M and Q. My stop
loss was a 15-minute closure below. As
you can see, price went from 526 all the
way up to 53180.
It's about a 250 point move on 2M andQ.
That's a,000 bucks. If you take one MNQ,
500 bucks. Obviously, you're not going
to hold it the whole way. I secure my
trades for about $60 profit. I believe
that's my average win. And I'll pull
that up right now on my top step. My
average win is 6624.
Uh 6424. My average loss is 6734.
My average win duration 11 minutes. My
average loss duration is 24 minutes.
Average trade duration itself 15 minutes
34 seconds. Keep it as simple as
possible. Your validation or
invalidation is based on where the
candle closes.
The next thing you're going to add to
your chart is your previous days 50.
Now, this is any high or low made
between 4 a.m. EST and that 7:45 p.m.
EST candle. In this case, our low was
made right at London at 4:00 a.m. and
our high was made up here at about 11
o'clock. Now, we drag that out to the
right. And there are your next three
levels to take a play at. This gives you
your bias for the day. If we are below
London, excuse me, if we're below
previous days 50, that is a bearish bias
for the day. If we are above it, that is
a bullish bias for the day. So, how did
I read this chart Friday, June 13th,
going into the day? This is the only
thing that I draw on my charts. These
two gone boxes for the day, previous
days 50 and London 50. You could wake up
at 8:30 a.m., draw them in, and then
you're trading right at open.
For previous days 50, we were under
that. So, I have a bearish bias going
into the day. And then for the London
50, we are above that London 50. So, I
have a bullish bias for the day. What I
would have liked to see was price go
from the London 50 first test previous
days low which it did and then next test
would be at previous days 50 which it
did.
London 50 bounced. You can take 2 MNQ
long and your price target is London
high. You can secure the trade there. I
do in most cases I like to secure my
trades as I just showed you. $60 in the
profit or you can let it run with a stop
loss at break even, stop loss at $50 in
the profit, wherever tickles your fancy.
After you break London high, your next
target is previous day's low. If it is
already within previous day's low or
previous day's range, your next target
is previous day 50 or previous day high.
In this case, our next target was
previous day's low. We broke that,
continued up. Next target would be
previous days 50.
Beautiful move up to previous day's 50.
And then that confirms your bearish bias
for the day as we rejected off of
previous days 50 extremely hard. And
then where did we bounce again? London
50 over and over and over again into
close. And that is the trading model
itself. You take 2 MNQ at either of the
50s. You take 1 MNQ at the high or low
of that range. and your stop loss is a
15minute closure. Now, in this case, if
I had taken short at previous days 50, I
would have been stopped out right here
at noon. The stop loss on that trade
maybe 50 bucks or you could have been a
little risky, held it, re-entered on
that retest at 12:45 and then
capitalized on the 250 point move back
to the downside. This is all I do every
single day. And that's why my trading
platform on Topstep looks like this.
It's a simple strategy, free tool on
Trading View.
Weak magnet and the gone box. That's it.
There's no fancy indicators on here.
There's no complex terms that I'm not
going to understand.
Simple as that. Now, for the Asia
session trading, all you do is mark out
that previous day's 50.
So, for this session, Friday, June 13th.
Uh, bad example. Actually, there's no
futures trading on Friday afternoon. Uh,
let's go into Monday. So, Monday, we're
marking out our previous days 50. 4 a.m.
was the low and then our high was made
at about 11:15. Drag that out to the
right. Our reaction levels for Asia's
session after that 8 pm close is any
rejection at the 50, the zero or the
one. That's it. Now what I do on top
since you can't see Asia session on cues
for trading view whatever your trading
platform is whether it be trade of eight
project X topep X
all I do is kind of eyeball it. So, in
this case, uh, for Monday, June 16th,
I'll scroll back to Monday, June 16th.
This is our range for the day.
I eyeball it over to MNQ.
So, there's our low, there's our high.
Drag it out to the right.
Now, remember, London 50 is made at 4
a.m., but this one is a little
different, isn't it? Looks a little bit
odd. That's where I go and eyeball it. I
look for
uh candles that I can identify in both
charts. In this case, let's look at
9:15.
Okay, that previous day's 50 lines up
with about the top of that opening red
candle. So, I go and identify that
candle on Q's. Okay, it's right there. I
drag it up until it conforms to where it
should be on Q's.
So that looks about about right. Lines
up with the high of that candle. Lines
up with the high of that 9:15 candle.
Drag it out to the right. That 50 is
where I'm taking the reactions for Asia
Asa Asia session. I couldn't say that. A
little embarrassing there. That 50 is
where I'm taking those reactions for the
8:00 PM to say I trade until midnight,
whatever it might be. In this case, we
had a fake out, came back over. I could
have taken bounces off all those 50 uh
retests.
In this case, we wicked to it about five
times. This one would have been a fake
out. Okay, you get stopped out. Your
risk was I'll zoom way in because how
low the risk was. Uh close below on the
15minute. Let's say you entered right at
22,040. This candle closed at 22,38. You
just risk two points for that upside
potential. and then the very next candle
actually pushed up 70 points.
So be it. The strategy itself has a very
low risk because you typically retest
the 50 depending on which way you're
going. Now you might be thinking to
yourself, "This guy's telling me the 50,
but he's red on the day. What an idiot."
The losses are going to happen. As I
just went over with this trade, the 50
is not always going to retest or bounce
perfectly. The first example that I gave
you for this London 50 was a perfect
perfect
uh example doesn't always happen.
Sometimes it closes just under you get
stopped out and then the trade runs 70
points in the direction you wanted it
to. That's okay. It's going to happen.
For today's trading,
this is why I ended up losing today.
Now, as you can see, I don't have the
50s marked on MNQ because I trade them
on Q's. Again, this is all free on
Trading View. I'm going to use it for
free. Trading View has very good data
for Q's and ES.
And that's why I prefer using Q's as
opposed to going on MNQ. MNQ has some
slippage as some errors on the reads.
That's why I prefer Q's. For today, I
marked out previous days 50, Wednesday,
June 18th. We had the market closed
yesterday uh for Junth. And then we had
the market back open today on Friday. I
marked out previous days 50. The low was
made after FOMC
right here. Uh this was all overnight
trading. So I do not incorporate this.
The 4 a.m. candle was right here. The
low was made for FOMC. The high was made
at about 10:30 in the morning. So that's
my previous day's 50. Now my London 50.
London low was right at 4:00 a.m. uh
4:45 a.m., excuse me. London high was
made just before open at 9:15. That's my
London 50. So, I will draw that out real
time so you can see. London low, weak
magnet snap to it. London high, just
kind of eyeball that one and drag it out
to the right. Those are my levels to
play for the day. We have our previous
day's high, London high, previous days
50 and London 50 lined up perfectly. and
then previous day's low and London low.
I took longs on the closure over
previous day's high as well as London
high with 1 M and Q. I averaged in a
little bit to 3M and Q max. Ended up
losing about 355 on that trade and that
was actually the worst trade that I've
had on this account.
Next, I took longs twice at previous
days 50 and London50 and I ended up
making about 250 bucks. Those were both
2 M and Q trades.
Uh the first one I secured for about 70.
The second one I secured for about 130,
127 depending on slippage. And then as
you can see, we fell through. I ended up
losing about 103 on this.
And then I traded a few more times with
one MNQ,
2 MNQ. I recovered about 130 140 bucks
with some losses thrown in there. So
down 37 on the day.
Not going to revenge trade. No need for
that because the strategy is going to
perform next week and it's going to
perform the week after that and the week
after that. This is a volumebased
strategy. That's why there's so many
trades on my performance stats. This is
a volumebased strategy, meaning that you
take a trade either 1 M and Q at the
London high, previous day's high, 2 MNQ
at the previous day's 50, London 50, or
1 M and Q at the previous day's low,
London low. You're taking a trade every
time you react at one of these levels.
You can cut it, call it quits whenever
you want to, as you can see. I typically
do uh when I'm up, in this case, 200,
I'm happy with that. 500, very happy
with that. 1,600 ecstatic
across five accounts. That $200 day is
a,000 bucks. $1,600 day, that's $8,000.
$1,000 day, $5,000.
Take the green when you see the green.
Do not hold onto the position for the
big home run. This is a base hit type
strategy.
Has about a 70% win rate, maybe a little
bit higher, maybe a little bit lower.
The thing that is going to adjust this
is the trading psychology. If you take
one loss, like I did today, 350 bucks,
and then you immediately just start
revenge trading longs until it either
hits your price target or you blow the
account, this is not the strategy's
fault. That is your fault. The trading
psychology is very, very easy with this
because your your plan, your stop loss,
and your takerit is all presented to
you. If you hit London 50, your next
target is London low or London high. If
you hit previous days 50, your next
target is previous day's high or
previous days low. See the green when
you take the green. That's exactly what
I do. If I'm up 50 bucks, I'm very happy
to take $50 times five accounts, 250
bucks made in less than 15 minutes. If
it retraces back down and hits that
level again, I reenter that same trade.
Say it goes up 100 bucks like it did
this morning. very happy to take that
100 bucks times five. $500 in less than
15 minutes.
These are base hits that compound. 50
trades. Holy That's a whole bunch
of trades. That's way too many. He's
overtrading. Wait a minute. 785 bucks
times five. 3,500.
Almost 4,000 bucks. 52 trades.
41 7 22. What's going on here?
You take a trade when it reacts at the
levels. Your stop loss 15-minute closure
over, under, depending on where you get
into the trade. If I get into it at the
50, stop loss is a 15-minute close over
or under.
That's how simple the strategy is and
that's how simple you can make trading.
There's no need for complex terms.
There's no need for indicators that are
going to muck up your chart. Like if I
had rips EMAs, VWAP, posty pivots,
whatever it might be. This chart is a
whole lot more difficult to read than a
chart that looks like this.
Keep it simple, stupid. That's the motto
I go by. And you don't need a
subscription for this. I do have a
subscription because I like to look at
other charts. But if you want to be as
cheap as possible, you get one combine
futures account, whatever it might be,
and trading view for free. I hope you
enjoyed this video. If you want to check
out my live trading every single day
within the Discord, that link is going
to be in my YouTube bio as well as the
description of this video.
Any other questions, drop them in the
comments. Drop a like, subscribe. I will
see you guys later for another video.
Peace out.